[Music]
I knew there was something about him
from the moment I met him honestly
well it appears that things are just
cheeky for Arielle winter and her
boyfriend leave I'm Eden I met him and I
thought to myself I was like you know I
don't know what it is but there's
something about him that's so
interesting and turns out it was so it
was it big something just days after the
Modern Family star revealed she was
quote in the process of deleting all
social media
she returned to Instagram to share a few
pics from her fourth of July celebration
at Nobu in Malibu
including this hot shot of her 30-year
old beau grabbing a handful of her
derriere et caught up with winters man
in March and he dished on how their
relationship has changed since moving in
together less beer I guess that's it
that's the only thing we're we're
happier than ever we got three dogs we
adopted a bunny there may be another one
on the way I guess more animals that's
what's changed there was two dogs to
begin with now we've got another dog and
a rabbit so in a year maybe I don't know
a full farm
[Music]